i want to talk about a really good
remedy for angina
as well as any type of irregular
heartbeat
and this natural remedy would be a good
thing to keep around someone with
pre-existing heart problems heart
failure
past heart attacks especially if you're
flying on a plane
keep it with you and the remedy is
called hawthorne berry
extract it's been used for a very long
time for
all sorts of circulatory problems as
well as respiratory illness
specifically irregular heartbeats
hypertension
chest pain harding of the arteries as
well as other symptoms related to heart
failure
like difficulty breathing as well as
fatigue
but today it's primarily used for angina
that's
chest pain because it increases blood
flow and it helps to restore
a normal heartbeat there's quite a bit
of research on this natural remedy
demonstrating significant improvements
in heart
function increased ability to exercise
after someone had heart failure it was
found to be just as effective
as the medication captopril which is for
heart conditions
and there's also improvements in
shortness of breath and fatigue
now how does it create these very cool
effects well there are certain
phytonutrients in this natural
uh plant that helps dilate the blood
vessels
increasing blood flow as well as
protecting the
inside the vessel from oxidation
and free radical damage now before
taking this remedy or any remedies to
replace your medication check with your
doctor first
i'm not recommending this is going to
cure your heart or
replace any medicine now the two
compounds they isolated that create the
most effect
are number one pro anthocyanins as well
as the
bioflavonoids these two natural
compounds have a very specific effect
of relaxing the coronary artery
which is many times involved in a heart
attack because it can go into a spasm
and so this is why i say that this would
be a good thing to take if you're
traveling
if you're on a plane if you're out and
about keep some in your pocket
just in case hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content
i would love to hear about your success
story
please share it in the link down below